Alright, so now that we have a handle on this
kind of representation, let's look at some things we can do
with it. So, here's an example of a Bayesian network
with five variables. A, B, C, D, E. And let's pretend
that each one has some set of possible values. Could
be true/false. Could be red, green, blue. Whatever it happens to
be. And these arrows again tell us about our conditional dependence
relationships. So how would we go about actually well, say sampling
from this distribution? So let's say that we wanted to just
as an example see what A, B, C, D, and E, might
look like in a, in a randomly selected example from the
distribution that this network represents. So turns out what we can do
is that if we sample from A. Now A is specified
has no incoming arrows so it's not conditioned on anything in particular
so we can sample directly from A's distribution. We can do
the same for B and now C. If we want to sample
from C, we need to, make use of what values have already
been selected for A and B. Because C is conditioned on A
and B. But we can sample from that distribution. Each, each value
of A and B, each joint value of A and B gives
a distribution over C. And we do the same thing for D
and the same thing for E. And we're done. What we've sampled
from is actually the probability distribution,
the joint probability distribution. So does
that seem like a useful thing to be able to do Charles?
>> It does seem like a useful thing to be able to do.
>> Yeah, so here's just a quickie quiz. So just write
a one word description that says, well in this sampling you'll notice
I went a, b, c, d, and e. What ordering do
I need to do if I have a belief net like this
specified by this graphical structure with the arrows? If I want
to be able to sample it, I need to do it in
a particular order. Some orders are, are going to be problematic because
we haven't actually, you know, sampled the variables that it depends on.
So, what ordering should we select for A, B, C, D, E? In general, what, what is
the name for that. So that we can
actually do this kind of sampling trick this way.
>> Okay.